[Music]
darren
is with us in los angeles starting off
this hour hi darren how are you
good thank you dave and anthony for
taking my call sure i'm
trying to make this quick um so
basically
i'm considering moving out for the first
time i'm 25
and the only debt i have is a car
payment
it's about 7400
and i have about 4 000 saved up
and my concern is moving out should i go
and
rent first should i stay home longer and
save so i could buy
something what are you doing right now
for a career-wise uh
uh darren um i i just started a job
about three months ago
um doing sales and um and how much how
much you make a year
is it commission yeah it's actually
commission only and
uh on average i made about 3
600 a month okay so and you're living in
los angeles california so you know i'm
from that area my brother lives in los
angeles right now
average rent out there is going to run
you in between 19 and 2 300
a month for just a 500 square foot
apartment
yeah and so now i look farther out into
the ie
so it's a little less expensive i think
the cheapest i found is like between
like thousand two hundred okay and uh
up okay here's gonna be my suggestion
um you have four thousand dollars in the
bank you have seven thousand dollars on
your car
uh you're young you're working you're
not using your parents
uh just to be using them i'm gonna say
give yourself one more year
pay off the car dave's looking at me
like what i'm gonna say i want you to
pay off your car
i want you to get some more money
emergency funds because once you step
out into the la world
the cost of living is a little bit more
expensive than twelve hundred dollars a
month
so that's going to be my suggestions um
at this time
i wouldn't wait a year okay i would go
faster than that
um if you're gonna stay home then put
four thousand dollars on the car today
and pay off the car next month and then
pile up a little cash and that'll give
you a cushion by then your job should be
stabilized
and i think you can be gone by christmas
yeah that's me yeah yeah because i was
just nervous about um
going out there with a car loan that's
why i was playing and paying that off
because yeah i think you're gonna pay
four down on it now and pay 3 000
next month you ain't got any overhead
yeah so if you make three if you make
four thousand next month
and you put four thousand on it today
that that car is paid for next month
then you the next month you save up
three or four thousand dollars to make
your leap
and you make your leap with no car
payment you're out of there by christmas
right that's what i'm doing i can rock
with that are you is that three thousand
dollars net or gross
uh net uh okay all right well that's
cool
yeah well well done i mean you can by
then you also kind of have your
your you know your straight commission
job you will have proven yourself to
yourself
yeah and you know you're going to be
okay so um
i'm just big on letting go of the seat
so you can ride
i'm not going to run along behind you
and hold the seat very long now that was
a daughter would you say the same thing
absolutely absolutely none of mine lived
with me after college
denise did for three months while she
was just getting organized
but that was it and it's just really
good
for your emotional development to buy
your own food at the grocery store and
pay your own electric bill
i like just it just it just changes your
manhood your womanhood it just changes
the sense of adulthood
and um and really good things happen in
your life
from that and um i agree
now if there was some kind of a crisis
or some kind of a problem or something
that's okay but
but um you know let go of the seat
let the bike ride i know they're gonna
wobble yeah
weebles wobble but they don't fall down